âge et de demander à chacune des
personnalités auditionnées de prêter
serment
je rappelle et je les fais à chaque fois
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois a doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je vous remercie si vous le
souhaitez vous pourriez introduire notre
échange par un propos liminaire je vous
donne la parole
éclairé mais alors de loin la commission
puisque que contrairement à l'idée
répandue ni le président ni le directeur
du cnaps dans le pouvoir ni de délivrer
ni de retirer les cas la construction
qui a été fait pour le club avec
l'inspecteur général de l'administration
chez berlioz a été justement de faire en
sorte que l'outil soit le plus
décentralisée possible et le moins
soumis possible à toute tentation ou
toute tentative de délivrer ou de
retirer des cartes pour des raisons qui
ne sont pas expressément prévues par le
législateur où le pouvoir exécutif
lorsqu'il exerce sa mission
réglementaire et donc ce sont des
présidents de commissions locales qui
sont soit des magistrats soient des
préfets qui exerce cette mission et la
commission d'appel la commission
nationale d'agrément et de contrôle
et comme ceci a été indiqué précédemment
sous l'autorité conjointe d'un membre du
conseil d'état et d'un magistrat de la
cour de cassation
alternativement l'un ou l'autre mais
personne d'autre et le pouvoir exercé
par le président du clap ce nous avons
fait en sorte qu'il ne puisse pas être
membre de la commission d'agrément et de
contrôle dans une stricte séparation des
pouvoirs telle qu'elle a été d'ailleurs
imposé au fil des ans pour toutes les
autorités ayant un pouvoir disciplinaire
car le cnap s'exerce à la fois une
mission de police administrative une
fonction d'ordre professionnel et des
missions de sanctions non seulement 10
culinaire mais financières dans des
conditions qui ont été prévus dans
certains cas par législateur dans
d'autres cas plus ou moins bricoler et
dans certains cas avec des difficultés
d'exercice c'est le cas par exemple pour
la mission de retrait en urgence des
cartes mission qu'il n'existe pas alors
que le collège du cnap cela réclame de
manière régulière bien avant le cas qui
vous a
intéressé aujourd'hui c'est à dire que
nous pouvions par exemple délivrer des
sanctions financières mais nous ne
pouvions pas les percevoir ni vérifier
qu'elles l'étaient nous pouvions délivré
d interdiction d'exercice ou des
suspensions pour les entreprises mais
sans pouvoir les faire appliquer et pour
un très grand nombre d' enquête qui
dépasse la simple consultation des
fichiers et encore pas tous nous devons
relever d'une mission qui se rajoute à
celle innombrables qui sont confiées aux
policiers aux gendarmes ou aux autorités
des services de renseignement dans le
cas de processus de radicalisation qui
peuvent interférer donc nous avons à la
fois beaucoup de missions des pouvoirs
alternatif et beaucoup de contraintes
dans l'exercice en tout cas dans le
contrôle de l'exercice réel de ses
pouvoirs et donc nous sommes dans cette
configuration qui vous a été je crois
expliqué par directeur le dernier
directeur en titre mais même pas
l'actuel je ne crois pas en tout cas
mais qui pourrait évoluer même vous
expliquer depuis la création du club ce
qu'est la difficulté de l'exercice de
cette institution un peu baroque un peu
hybride qui a moins de pouvoir que
l'ordre des médecins mais qui a plus de
compétences qui a quelques limites à son
exercice donc le législateur comme le
gouvernement ont fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour rattraper le retard et nous mettre
en situation d'être plus efficaces ou
plus compétents
la cour des comptes lors d'un rapport
récent a indiqué à la fois tout ce qui
était les déficiences du cnaps
mais en indiquant qu' elle ne répondait
pas la problématique du cnaps lui-même
et des pouvoirs qui lui sont confiés ou
des moyens qui lui sont attribués et
donc c'est un assez long travail puis
que l'ensemble du processus législatif
évidemment prendre du temps même s'il
s'agit de corriger un oubli d'une demi
phrase dans un coin loin titre dans un
autre nous n'avions pas par exemple pas
de code de déontologie obligatoire c'est
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et le collège du cnaps
eux mêmes qui ont souhaité se l'appliqué
à lui-même
nous avons à la fois des catégories très
complexe de population puisque chez les
détectives privés nous avons parfois des
salariés de cabinet de détectives et des
professions libérales qui ne se traite
évidemment pas de la même manière et qui
nous font bien d'ailleurs savoir quand
nous sommes dans des processus par
exemple de contrôle de la réalité de la
concurrence et notamment la concurrence
étrangères sur le territoire national du
fait de la virtualisation les frontières
se sont beaucoup estompée et puis nous
avons ce que l'état nous impose
notamment ce qui est les agréments et
les habilitations par équivalence ou
encore récemment il ya quelques semaines
un nouveau texte impose d'accueillir et
d'intégrer des personnels issus du monde
militaire dans des conditions
extrêmement allégées
ce qui n'est pas toujours la position du
collège du clape ce qui en général est
plus sévère ou plus strictes ou
considérés comme tels que l'idée que
l'état se fait de notre mission pour
beaucoup de sujets donc voilà ce que je
voulais vous indiquer comme arrière fond
général sur à la fois l'ampleur des
missions et les limites de l'exercice de
ses missions
eu égard à la complexité de la volonté à
la fois du législateur dans certains cas
et du gouvernement dans l'autre merci de
ce propos liminaire monsieur jean pierre
sueur
monsieur le professeur vous devez vous
poser plusieurs questions de la première
est factuel et nonobstant ce que vous
venez de nous expliquer est ce que eux
les conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
donc été directeur du cnaps exercer des
missions au sein de cet organisme
les conditions dans lesquelles une carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privée et un agrément qualité de
dirigeant d'une société de sécurité
privée ont été attribué à monsieur
alexandre benalla vous paraissent tout à
fait régulière
même chose pour les demandes de carte
professionnelle d'agent de sécurité
privée et d'agrément qualité dirigeant
d'une société de sécurité privée et de
l'autorisation d'exercer de la direction
d'une entreprise peut attribuer à
monsieur vincent case ses mots alors du
point de vue de la réglementation de la
législation et des textes qui ont été
produits par le législateur et
l'autorité réglementaire
les autorisation initiale de monsieur
benallal ont été faites par le préfet
représentant direct de l'état il n'y
avait pas d'institutions collégiale pour
le délivrer son renouvellement de carte
est fait dans la plus parfaite
régularité sa demande d'habilitation et
d'agrément s'est fait après la fin de
mon mandat mais pour ce que j'en sais
aurais-je été président du clap cette
époque rien ne se serait opposé à sa
délivrance
la délivrance de la carte de monsieur
crasse effet parfaitement dans les mêmes
règles et dans le même respect strict
des textes et son refus d'agrément
dirigeant s'est fait dans le strict
respect des textes et l'absence de
constitution d'un dossier
complet oui le fait que monsieur benalla
soit adjoint au chef de cabinet du
président de la république
il n'était pas en 2014 oui mais après
après eux n'a pas posé de questions
relatif à une demande d'agrément pour
elisa ses nerfs que le statut des non
fonctionnaires contractuels de droit
public et s'oppose à 7
la possibilité à la fois parce qu'un
agrément il y à 325 peut-être un peu
moins 1000 cartes professionnelles dont
seulement 150 me d'actifs les autres ne
le sont pas c'est l'activité qui pose
problème la carte vous donne juste une
autorisation d'exercer
mais ne garantit pas l'exercice de cette
possibilité
c'est la même chose pour les agréments
des régions c'est une autorisation de
devenir des gens ce n'est pas le fait
que vous soyez dirigeants et
malheureusement la réglementation ne
prévoit rien d'autre que ce qui est déjà
le cas actuellement je vous ai donné je
vous ai imprimés ici une demande de
carte professionnelle
au cas où ça va voilà qui vous noterez
qu'à la fin de cette demande de carte
professionnelle
le collège a mis en place une
attestation qui interdit et qui rappelle
l'interdiction de cumul d'emplois avec
les fonctions publiques qui prévoit code
de la défense droits et obligations des
fonctionnaires au cumul d'activités des
fonctionnaires et qui demandent
expressément que et qui rappelle à celui
qui nous pose la question qu'ils
exercent ou pas d'activité qui lui est
interdit de l'exercer dans les cadres ou
la loi lui interdit expressément de le
faire nous sommes par a par contre face
à une difficulté je leur mets très
formellement du président
nous sommes par exemple par contre s à
une difficulté un militaire un
fonctionnaire de police un fonctionnaire
public qui prévoit sa retraite dans six
mois ou dans un an peut parfaitement à
ce titre demandé une demande de carte et
d'habilitation et l'exercé qu'au moment
où il n'est plus dans l'interdiction de
cumul il peut par ailleurs parfaitement
demandé à exercer le cumul notamment
s'il est employée à mi-temps ou dans
toute une série de dérogations qui
existe dans le code général de la
fonction publique qui sait de ce point
de vue là beaucoup élargie et a surgi au
fil des ans et donc il faut le traiter
au cas par cas
par ailleurs comme ceci vous a été
indiqué je crois précédemment nous
contrôlons normalement les cartes tous
les cinq ans c'est ce que faisaient les
préfectures depuis les problématiques
général indique notamment de lutte
antiterroriste des processus dit de
lutte contre la radicalisation
nous avons fait un contrôle général
avant l'euro 2016 pour des raisons qui
paraissait légitime à tous
nous faisons désormais un contrôle
général de l'ensemble des cartes tous
les deux ans je dis bien l'ensemble des
cartes 300 et quelques milles plus ce
qui scelle que nous délivrons tous les
ans environ 100000 puisque le rythme de
renouvellement s'accélère et que le taux
de rotation de la profession de la
sécurité privée notamment dans le
gainage est supérieure à 70% 70% dès
agents change soit d'emploi soit
d'employeurs tous les ans ce qui amène
un taux de rotation considérables et
donc une activité permanente du cnaps en
plus de du pic qui arrivent tous les
cinq ans des reprises d'activités des
reprises d'activité à temps partiel des
compléments d'activité en cas de besoin
majeur
imaginons les jeux olympiques par
exemple c'est un sujet totalement majeur
où le niveau de préparation reste
aujourd'hui encore très faible par
rapport aux besoins qui va s'exercer et
où probablement l'ensemble de la
population titulaires d'une carte va
revenir à ce moment précis si le cnap se
suit les instructions qui ont été
données au moment de l'euro 2016 et bien
toutes les cartes toutes les cartes vont
devoir être revisitée avant
l'ouverture du processus préalable aux
jeux olympiques et toute la durée des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques donc
ceci explique l'ampleur du dispositif
nécessaire pour fonctionner mais là
l'existence tant qu'elle n'est pas
publiée au journal officiel dans ce cas
précis et d'ailleurs nous ne sommes
peut-être pas au courant de l'activité
exact de monsieur benalla à l'elysée je
ne suis pas sûr que grand monde savait
très exactement ce qu'il y faisait avant
que la presse et les commission denquête
décide de révéler ce qui était la
réalité de ces contrats à ma
connaissance le fait qu'il ne
l'indiquent pas est la situation exacte
devait être regardée au vu de exactement
ce qu'ils faisaient des horaires qu'il
faisait mail interdit absolu en termes
de code général de la fonction publique
à ma connaissance ne s'appliquait pas à
son cas par ailleurs ne se serait pas
appliquée à sont capables merci nathan
suède deuxième question l'autorisation
du président a demandé là comment elle
est accordée va porter sur une question
plus générale
et là je voulais vous interrogez en tant
que spécialiste reconnu des questions de
sécurité
il y a deux entités à l'elysée chargé de
la sécurité de la protection du
président de la république
le gspr et le commandement militaire
les personnels exerçant les missions
dans ces deux organismes où ces deux
entités relève du ministère de
l'intérieur ou du ministère de la
défense en cotutelle pour ceux qui sont
militaires il a été dit par monsieur
benalla dans le journal du dimanche que
par rapport à ce qui pouvait être un
projet par rapport auquel nous ne savons
pas très exactement le rôle qu'il jouait
puisque nous avons plusieurs versions
il y avait une opposition du ministère
de l'intérieur peu et il quelle est
votre appréciation sur deux le rapport
des personnels qui s'occupe de sécurité
à la présidence de la république et le
ministère de l'intérieur ou de la
défense
il me semble que depuis le début de la
vème république
ces personnels appartiennent et sont
gérés par ces ministères qu'il ya donc
un lien y at il des cas où on imagine
dans des sociétés démocratiques ce lien
n'existe pas et eux
quelle appréciation auriez-vous sur une
évolution de ce lien dans le sens d'une
plus grande autonomie des personnels qui
exercerait la protection du président de
la république et sa sécurité
c'est bref la sécurité d'un chef d'état
se gère toujours dans des configurations
qui sont propres à l'histoire de chaque
pays ou à l'évolution de cette histoire
au gouvernement le président des états
unis était protégé par une société
privée qui s'appelait pinkerton après en
avoir perdu deux ou trois il a été
considéré plus utile de créer un service
le cycle frais de service qui a deux
missions la protection du président des
états unis et la lutte contre la fausse
monnaie
cet organisme est placé sous l'autorité
du secrétaire général de la présidence
la maison blanche mais avec une
dépendance administrative et
fonctionnelle qui relève en partie du
département de la justice
en tout cas budgétaire mais c'est une
très grande autonomie
vous avez des régiments de garde
présidentielle dans beaucoup de pays et
des mercenaires et des sociétés privées
dans d'autres chacun fait un peu comme
il veut où comme il peut pour des
raisons qui sont liés à la confiance la
stabilité l'instabilité des dispositifs
de sécurité ou une longue tradition de
coup d'état ou le sergent-chef machin
remplaçait l'ancien caporal truc en
fonction de considérations locales ou ce
qui se passe dans notre ex empire
colonial montre une certaine forme
d'instabilité chronique mais le
commonwealth britannique a connu ces
mêmes difficultés c'est 1 1 restent mal
heureux de la manière dont la stabilité
de ces pays cette mise en place en
france
curieusement il y a d'abord un épisode
très instable qui est entre la
libération et 1958 où on passe d'une
absence d'organisation structurée claire
eua par l'institution garde républicaine
qui ressemble à l'outil de protection
des institutions il n'y a pas d'outil
véritablement clair autour du général de
gaulle et dans la partie qui va aller
jusqu'à la la fin des événements
d'algérie puisque la détermination
exacte de guerre d'algérie samples est
toujours complexe
oui
il y à là l'apparition d' unité
paramilitaire de dispositifs qui sont
pas tout à fait prévu par la
constitution ou la réglementation
ensuite on revient à une situation plus
républicaine au moment où la paix civile
s'installe jusqu'à 1983 et la création
du gspr qui a été au fil du temps plus
policiers que gendarme ou plus gendarmes
que policiers sous la même dénomination
quant au commandant militaire il
appartient à l'institution qui protège
tous les édifices publics et pour
prendre un exemple n'ai pas souvenir
qu'il ya un groupe de sécurité du
premier ministre qui pourrait
parfaitement se justifier dans le cadre
de l'organisation actuelle de la vème
république
parce que ça n'a pas semblé nécessaire
et pourtant le premier ministre est
aussi bien protégé je le pense que le
président de la république mais dans un
autre style de configuration les choix
qui peuvent être faits sont extrêmement
divers la mise en cohérence d'un outil
de sécurité est un enjeu majeur il est
assez difficile d'avoir un outil qui
s'occupe du fixe et au cul d'un outil
qui s'occupe du mobile chacun sous un
chef différent et avec une organisation
complexe
enfin je précise que dans les missions
qui relèvent des responsables politiques
élus il ya plusieurs phases d'abord il
ya le fait de savoir qui les protègent
lorsqu'ils sont candidats et être
protégé par le ministre de l'intérieur
de la majorité sortante quand vous êtes
dans l'opposition est toujours un sujet
compliqué qui amène en général des
accommodements où on essaye de trouver
des policiers ou des gendarmes
républicain mais ayant une sorte d'
appartenance connu au camp d'en face
pour permettre à la fois que l'état
fasse son travail en protégeant les
candidats tout en faisant en sorte que
les candidats aient le sentiment d'être
en confiance et que les policiers ou les
gendarmes qui sont mis à leur
disposition ne fasse pas un rapport tous
les soirs au ministre de l'intérieur sur
tout ce qu'ils ont fait dit et pensé
durant la journée c'est un sujet de
confiance et donc il ya des
accommodements républicain relativement
connu d'ailleurs la presse se fait
l'écho de qui assume
la sécurité du candidat ou des candidats
de l'opposition en montrant bien que ça
s'est fait dans une sorte de de
cohérence générale ou qu'il ya un refus
d'ailleurs du candidat en question dont
je ne veux pas d'agent public parce que
je veux être sûr de mon entourage et il
ya donc des services d'ordre et les
organisations politiques disposent tout
syndical aussi d'ailleurs de service
d'ordre dont certains ont des missions
de protection rapprochée extrêmement
développée qu'on a d'ailleurs toujours
vu dans les campagnes présidentielle et
surtout pour les candidats les plus
exposés ou les plus à même de gagner
l'élection arrivé au pouvoir
la question se pose de la cohabitation
alors vous pouvez être nelson mandela
qui amène son unité de sécurité qui
vient directement de ce qu'on appelait
la lance de la nation le l'espace le
plus dur de la nc et qui explique aux
officiers bourg qui dirigeait le
gouvernement blanc et ségrégationniste
juste que désormais ils feraient ils
feraient cause commune il faut être
nelson mandela mais voilà ça
fonctionnait et dont il a intégré ces
unités un peu d'ailleurs comme beaucoup
d'officiers de la résistance sont
trouvés intégrés dans les institutions
de l'état avec reconnaissance de leurs
titres gagnés dans la clandestinité au
moment où l'état républicain s'est
rétabli après le régime de la
collaboration
vous avez le processus de rebond bas
maintenant c'est fini donc on est dans
une logique d'état donc toi tu restes au
siège du parti est désormais
l'état république assume sa fonction
c'est le cas du secret de services
américains il n'y a pas de contractuels
de sécurité privée auprès du président
des états unis il n'y en a pas auprès du
premier de grande bretagne
il n'y en a pas auprès de la chancelière
d'allemagne je n'ai pas connaissance
qu'il y en ai d'ailleurs dans aucun des
pays de l'union européenne ayant un
régime
démocratique c'est il ya une stricte
séparation mais on peut avoir à son
cabinet au sens de l'appareil politique
quelqu'un qui s'occupe dans la partie
des déplacements de la partie on va dire
semi privé ou semi politique et qui a
une fonction ou simplement de lien local
qui peut exister mais les choses sont
clairement définis et déterminé et puis
vous avez des pays où c'est très
exactement l'un vers ce le spoil system
est ainsi fait qu'en fait on ne fait
confiance à personne et donc une équipe
privée vient prendre le relais pour
assurer la sécurité est exact et
immédiate du chef de l'état ces choix
sont à la libre expression de nous
sommes une démocratie qu'à une vieille
histoire
je pense que la cohérence visant à ce
qu'il n'y ait que des agents publics
autour du président de la république
mais sous un commandement unique a du
sens parce que je vois pas très bien
comment on peut à la fois assurer la
sécurité résidentielle et la sécurité
des déplacements avec de commandement de
séparation deux unités mais c'est un
point de vue rationnel qui rentre pas
toujours en ligne de compte au moment où
on fait des choix plus personnel merci
de cette réponse monsieur bauer madame
un mois que monsieur sur est encore une
question non madame jourdain
c'est une question également d'ordre
général comme celle de mon collègue
co-rapporteur vous indiquez à l'instant
et c'est exact que la sécurité ça sur
différemment selon l'histoire de chaque
pays alors ma question porte évidemment
sur os sur la france et sur
l'appréciation vous pouvez avoir du
développement des activités de sécurité
privée et du développement aussi des
missions que le pont confié aujourd'hui
des agents de sécurité privés bien le
plus grand pardon monsieur paul est le
plus grand paradoxe de la situation
c'est que la sécurité privée résiste
avec détermination à la volonté de
l'état de lui confier des missions
toujours plus nombreuses et qui dépasse
très largement à la fois les limites que
le conseil des telles conséquences yen
ont rappelé à plusieurs reprises
je pense par tout particulièrement à la
voie publique et je pense spécifiquement
aux à la garde transfert et
hospitalisations des détenus l'état a
décidé depuis longtemps unilatéralement
alors il faut le savoir l'état a créé la
sécurité privée en france
c'est une action déterminée du préfet de
police de la seine
désormais paris qui a créé la première
société parisienne de surveillance qui
était une société avec des agents
supplétifs qui avaient des missions
assez spécifique sur les habitations bon
marché ancêtres dhb des hlm
et sur la mise en place d'outils
transport qui est un peu compliquée et
qui était le métropolitain parce que
c'était souterrain est un peu difficile
à gérer
1900 rapport du préfet de la seine
devant le conseil municipal de paris
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
hélas mais en tout cas c'est comme ça et
donc ils avaient besoin d' agents
supplétifs et il s'est dit on va créer
une société parisienne de surveillance
qui permettra de recycler quelques
gardiens de la paix et surtout d'avoir
une espèce de force annexe pour
s'occuper de tout ce qui m'intéresse pas
vraiment et qui en général statique peu
dynamique et et qui n'avait pas natale
et aînés ainsi l'histoire de la
surveillance et du gardiennage
les détectives c'est une histoire plus
ancienne dû essentiellement à l'action
de monsieur vidocq lui-même issu
contractuels de la sécurité publique de
la préfecture de police et qui
intervenait lui essentiellement sur la
fraude boursière car ça venait de se
développer
la police d'état n'en avait ni voyait
enfin comprenait pas ce que l'intérêt
que ça pouvait avoir les polices locales
encore moins il a trouvé un marché et
c'était le premier bureau du
renseignement universel et puis peu à
peu on a vu développé toute une série de
missions au fur et à mesure où l'état a
décidé de se retirer car en fait la
sécurité privée en france n'existe que
quand l'état se retire
l'état dit je ne veux plus assurer la
protection du transport de fonds bon eh
bien il faut bien que quelqu'un s'en
occupe
alors on demande à la poste de créer une
filiale puis on dit les étrangers vont
peut-être enfin les étrangers ou
d'autres qui ont une spécificité l'ont
peut-être s'installer et donc la
sécurité et le transport de fonds
s'installe et ça fait donc désormais une
trentaine d'années qu'il y à des agents
de sécurité privés armés contrairement à
ce que tout le monde raconte plusieurs
milliers je précise d'ailleurs qu'il
n'ya aucune entre guillemets bavure
recensé de ses agents ils font plus
souvent tiré dessus qu'il ne tire sur
des gens
notre cas ils sont présents ils sont là
et ça fait très longtemps la troisième
paire catégorie a étaient les ports et
transport je trouve que
j'étais à l'époque avec michel rocard à
matignon et donc deux lois ont prévu la
privatisation et la sous traitance du
contrôle et de la surveillance des
passagers et des bagages dans les ports
puis dans les aéroports puis élargie aux
ports maritimes 90 puis les stadiers
sont arrivés dans une configuration un
peu complexe et peu à peu l'état à créer
de nouveaux dispositifs
jusqu'au moment où il a imaginé qu'il
pouvait encore élargir le champ en
ouvrant par exemple la garde armée des
navires lagarde a remis des navires se
fait hors territoire national mais pose
des problèmes qui était que les navires
français n'était donc plus gardés par
des anglo saxons avec les problématiques
de souveraineté que s'imposait pour une
partie importante de la flotte
ensuite c'est poser le problème des
gardes armés le préfet c'est laid était
optimiste en disant que c'était interdit
puisque la créativité bureaucratique du
ministère de l'intérieur était sans
limites puisque si les gardes armés
étaient interdits dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions d'agents de protection
rapprochée il avait le droit de porter
une arme car le simple fait qu'il soit à
côté d'une cible les autoriser a demandé
larmes pour eux parce qu'ils étaient à
côté de la personne qu'ils devaient
protéger et donc en fait il y avait une
centaine de personnes qui étaient armés
en france dans des conditions de
légalité extrêmement contestable et
c'est après laffaire charlie hebdo que
le gouvernement a décidé de sortir de
l'ambiguïté du bricolage et de ce qui
était toléré y compris pour des
accompagnants de personnalités
étrangères qui n'étaient pas eux mêmes
agents publics et donc hors des
conventions internationales diplomatique
de protection des dirigeants en visite
qui a permis de sortir de ce flou et de
cette ambiguïté avec le fameux texte qui
va enfin prochainement entrer en
application
de la même manière il existe des gardes
armés sur des entreprises d'état qui
sont désormais semi privatisée et qui
pour des raisons de souveraineté
nationale ou dangereux comme le
nucléaire par exemple le protègent
certaines installations
donc il ya un grand bricolage qui a été
fait tout ça appartient à un espace où
il ya une sorte de consensus général sur
les limites de l'exercice
là où il n'y a pas consensus et où
l'état est souvent demande
heures dans des conditions qui me paraît
extraordinairement dangereuse c'est la
protection de la voie publique et la
garde le transfert et le spi tation des
détenus et tout ce qui relève de
l'administration pénitentiaire ce sont
des pulsions que j'ai dont j'espère
qu'elles sont résistible mais qui
prennent régulièrement l'état qui a une
vision assez large de tous de ce dont il
pourrait se débarrasser au bénéfice de
la sécurité privée et je tiens à dire
dont le collège du claps en tout cas
avec les représentations de toutes les
orientations prochaine a déjà expliqué à
plusieurs reprises à l'unanimité qu'il
n'en voulait pas merci beaucoup monsieur
grosdidier à moi que pardon monsieur
monsieur sur un propos du port d'armes
vous paraît-il justifier que parmi le
personnel de l'elysée titulaire aux
contractuels d'autres personnes que
celles appartenant au commandement
militaire et au gspr soit détenteur d'un
port d'armes
un variateur réponse à votre question la
première réponse et n'importe qui peut
demander un port d'armes
n'importe qui voilà donc c'est un sujet
qui nécessite de revoir la question du
port d'armes au sens de l'appréciation
personnelle qui est fait à chaque
demande individuelle le port d'armes de
manière opérationnelle le plus sûr moyen
d'avoir un accident un assassinat ou une
bavure c'est de créer des commandements
différents avec des individus
appartenant à des chaînes différentes
ayant des pratiques différentes une
formation différente une compétence
différentes au même endroit tous avec
des moyens létaux donc la réponse est à
titre individuel je vois aucune autre
difficulté que l'appréciation qui est
fait d'une demande personnelle pour
dames à titre opérationnel la réponse et
il ne peut y avoir et il ne doit y avoir
qu'un seul opérateur une seule chaîne de
commandement et un seul dispositif à la
fois de formation de connaissance de
confiance de réactivité et donc il est
clair que pour la deuxième partie la
réponse est non d'évaluation et de
coordination rouge
merci monsieur power est effectivement
là c'est pas si vous avez regardé toutes
les auditions mais cela donne à
réfléchir
relativement à votre préconisations
unité dans la chaîne de commandement
c'est tout c'est un commentaire
alors monsieur grosdidier vous êtes un
spécialiste du droit comparé et aussi un
observateur des différents dispositifs
existants par le monde vous l'avez
évoqué d'ailleurs de ce que ça pouvait
dans des démocraties balbutiantes ou
dans des régimes des régimes
autoritaires et et instable mais y at il
des exemples dans les grandes
démocraties bien installé ancien de
dispositifs de sécurité du président
complètement dissociés il ya des forces
qui normalement relève du gouvernement
et même pouvant échapper à l'état de
droit je veux dire je m'explique on a eu
un un exemple d'autonomisation complète
du de la protection du président à
l'égard du mystère de l'intérieur lors
des dérives dire de ces gendarmes qui à
l'époque est indienne se permettait même
s'autoriser même des écoutes
téléphoniques
et quand elles étaient commandés pouvait
invoquer le régime d'immunité du
président de la république dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions
donc si certes nous respectons tout sa
séparation des pouvoirs nous souhaitons
d'ailleurs qu'elle soit respectée à
l'égard du parlement
est ce que au nom de principes
démocratiques anciens de la séparation
des pouvoirs
on peut justifier une séparation au sein
de l'exécutif entre la sécurité
présidentielle et celles relevant du
gouvernement et notamment du ministère
de l'intérieur d'ailleurs y avait un
projet d'autonomisation complète de la
sécurité élyséenne à l'égard du mime du
ministère de l'intérieur dan façon
est-ce qu'on peut contester fait pour le
parlement qui dans toutes les
démocraties contrôle les services de
sécurité lui contester le droit de
de contrôle également la sécurité de la
présente offre publique aux ados qu'en
est il en droit comparé et ce que ce
serait s'il était confirmé en france
veut une singularité française que
d'avoir un système de protection lysiens
qui échappe au lit ça de l'intérieur et
est une cause et une impossibilité pour
le parlement de contrôler la sécurité de
la présidence de la république c'est la
possibilité éventuelle d'une
cohabitation s'est beaucoup réduit
d'après les constitutionnalistes au
moment où il y a eu la confusion des
deux élections dans un délai rapproché
dans le même temps la dissolution d'une
chambre n'est pas impossible et le fait
qu'il y ait un président d'une couleur
et un gouvernement ou une majorité
parlementaire du nôtre est une
possibilité la question est est-ce qu'il
s'agit dans ce cas précis d'un risque
pour que l'autorité présidentielle soit
combattue par un ministère de
l'intérieur - républicains qu'il ne l'a
été jusqu'à présent je rappelle que lors
des périodes de cohabitation le choix du
ministre de l'intérieur faisait l'objet
d'un dosage extraordinairement
particulier nonobstant la réalité du
résultat de l'élection législative ou de
la majorité des deux chambres donc on
sent bien qu'il ya là une sensibilité
particulière alors quand on respecte les
statuts du président de la république et
du premier ministre dont le niveau
d'équivalence reste fort
on peut arriver à s'en sortir s'il ya un
conflit majeur
l'idée que la sécurité du chef de l'état
chef des armées et par ailleurs ayant
désormais des pouvoirs relativement
élargie notamment avec la création du
conseil de sécurité intérieure sur
proposition du préfet massoni et sous
leur décision du président chirac montre
qu'on est quand même dans un espace un
peu compliqué moi je suis très partisans
du contrôle
ça me paraît être une nécessité
parlementaire contrôle budgétaire
contrôle effectif du point de vue de
l'autonomie et de l'indépendance de la
capacité du président de la république
lorsqu'il n'est pas en situation de
majorité parlementaire mais qu'il est
toujours le président de l'apic choisi
au suffrage universel
le fait qu'il y ait là un effort de
compréhension particulière me semble
raisonnablement compréhensible il l'a
été jusqu'à présent sans obligation de
modifier les textes mais chacun se
rappelle que le gps air sous jacques
chirac n'est pas le même que sous
françois mitterrand il n'est pas non
plus le même sous nicolas sarkozy et la
configuration actuelle montre qu'il
n'est pas non plus voilà il donc il ya
des modalités d assouplissement des
complexités qu'il faut prendre en
considération ce qui m'amène à dire que
plutôt que d'attendre le moment de la
crise
pour gérer ce problème à la française
c'est toujours au moment où alors qu'on
aurait pu le faire bien avant de manière
calme et tranquille peut-être le moment
est effectivement venu de mettre à plat
la manière dont fonctionne un service de
la sécurité présidentielle mais comme je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure la question se
pose aussi d'une manière différente pour
le premier espace caprio il est le chef
de la majorité et on peut considérer
qu'il n'aura pas les mêmes relations
avec son ministre de l'intérieur que le
président de la république dans le cas
d'une cohabitation dans tout état de
cause le fait de remettre à plat des
dispositifs qui ont vieilli et qui sont
plus tout à fait adaptées aux
problématiques par exemple des drones
aux problématiques de la modification de
la troisième dimension de la sécurité
d'un espace qui a beaucoup changé sur le
cyber notamment ça mériterait une remise
en place et je pense d'ailleurs que de
ce point de vue là c'est autant au
parlement qu'à l'exécutif de remettre à
plat les dispositifs de sécurité des
institutions de la république
certainement monsieur madame merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
professeur ès au criminologue vous avez
comme nous vu cette photo de monsieur
benalla avec l' arme au poing
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous inspire
cette attitude de quelqu'un qui se dit
un professionnel de la sécurité
et est-ce qu'un tel comportement est
fréquent j'ai rarement vu des scènes
fille de campagne où on essaie
d'impressionner la serveuse avec un bloc
ça je dois dire que c'est plutôt une
nouveauté les réseaux sociaux sont
passés par là
d'un point de vue professionnel
c'est contraire à l'ensemble des règles
de porc d'usagé et de maniement des
armes donc de celui là il n'y a pas
photo s'ils passaient un examen ils
auraient zéro et le 0 2 point de vue là
est plutôt une note éliminatoire
peut-être ajouter que ça n'est pas légal
de porter une arme dans les conditions
de laquelle il apportait alors ce moment
précis son autorisation d'après ce que
j'en sais ne le permettait pas donc là
je suis entré sur le domaine purement
prochaine je n'ai pas géré la partie
légale mais il semble qu effectivement
l'autorisation dont il disposait à
l'époque ne lui permettait pas non
seulement de l'exhiber mais encore moins
de la portée et bien s'il n'y a pas
d'autres questions je vois qu'il n'y en
a pas d'autre monsieur boisvert il me
reste à vous remercier d'avoir apporté
votre éclairage à notre commission
la séance est levée mais chers collègues